two false alarms on the strip just days
apart these situations were not
connected but they still created a lot
of panic and a lot of fear so what
should you do if you think you've heard
gunfire sasha loftus spoke to experts
tonight joining us live on the strip to
explain
denise and brian these were both false
alarms but for those who were there they
felt like anything but the experts i
spoke with tonight shed some light on
why these mass panic situations are
happening and what you should do if the
worst happens
i'm sorry we got to evacuate there's
been an active shooting this was the
scene saturday on the las vegas strip
then on wednesday at fashion show mall
people running terrified thinking there
was an active shooter both were false
alarms but those who were there say the
threat felt real it's very scary knowing
that you know things like that are
happening every day if you're constantly
on edge especially if you hear a loud
noise in a crowd you're not alone the
hyper vigilance is what the society is
living in right now dr sid karuna
medical director of nevada mental health
says the regularity of mass shootings in
america has made most people
subconsciously scan for threats those
trauma reminders are happening so our
brain doesn't even get a chance to
forget about that so how can we prevent
this kind of panic
jonathan alvarez ceo of protective force
international says do your best to stay
calm and listen to authorities listening
to everybody who has a uniform on and is
directing you to safety is imperative
and if you do need to get out fast
stay low and pay attention to your exit
options to keep everyone safe no matter
how scary something may seem it's hard
when there's so many people that are
scared that it's going to happen
dr karuna said in a situation of mass
panic some people also might experience
what's called perceptual trauma it is
referenced to if you see or hear
something that you think is a threat
which is driven by fear but didn't
actually happen reporting live tonight
sasha loftis live local now